this is not the first time that what
we're going to do is take a new idea
right it's actually an old ID you've met
before let's dress up a new language but
once you dress up a new language you can
take it further okay you've been working
with polynomials for a very long time
you just maybe have never called them
that ok so just underneath your hanging
a zit example okay
polynomials that you've met before are
things like say 2x plus 5 that's a
polynomial whoa groundbreaking all right
we spend a lot of time looking at
quadratics quadratic expressions
quadratic equations factorizing it is on
you guys know what my favorite quadratic
is that's it right there
that's also a polynomial okay you could
push on this a little bit more you can
see I thought there's something to the
power of Y I've got something too hard -
what's a call when you've got something
with power three it's called a cubic
right so this is another example I could
have something like oh I don't know
3x cubed minus 4x I don't know whatever
you like okay all of these things this
is a whole family of functions
remember what functions are you can put
a value in and you'll get a value out
this is all family of functions and
they're all called polynomials you guys
know my obsession macmaine's polynomials
very very simple phrase what's poly mean
yeah multiple mini right so for example
were you talking about polygons which
are shapes would have which I have many
angles right we took about polyester
which is a material made of a whole
bunch of other materials okay
I'm going talk about polymers which are
like plastics that are made up in anyway
you get the idea okay so it means many
nerdy yours
that's a weird phrase in our context
what it means is terms it's something
which has many terms you can see I've
got a whole bunch of terms I can have as
many times as I like I don't have to
stop it um you know excuse I can make
them big old small or whatever our life
okay there's a very specific example of
polynomials which is
this goes here this here is called a
binomial because it has two terms in
them right this is a binomial by
extension you'd call this a trinomial
and so on okay so all that means is I've
just got a whole bunch of terms but the
terms are very specific
can you see you've always got something
in there race two powers and then you've
got numbers out the front okay so let's
introduce some language and we use on
we'll use this guy here no I'll do it
I'll do one more example let's make it
let's make it bless you okay here we go
so I'm just going to use this as my
example and we're going to attach some
language to this okay firstly these are
all polynomials these are all
polynomials but the reason why I've
given you these four as my first
examples is because they come up so
frequently they all the special names
when you have things that come up again
and again and again people like oh
that's kind of cool let's talk about
that one so the first one that we've got
because if you draw this thing you'll
get a straight line okay this is called
a linear polynomial okay if you draw a y
equals 2x plus 5 you just get a straight
line okay we already know what these
guys are called with this power up here
is a tube we call these quadratic so
this is a quadratic polynomial couple of
minutes ago you told me this is a cubic
polynomial and this last one here like
you can see these have to do with the
number there's a there's a 2 here and a
3 here and a 4 here okay so these guys
yeah I called vortex okay if it's a
power five you get a quintic and after
that you kind of they stopped all
calling them special names because they
don't come up very often okay at least
in the mathematics that we're doing so
one two three four these are particular
kinds of polynomials and to talk a
little more specifically there's all
these different pieces in the polynomial
that we need to know about okay what
number is more important than all the
rest okay what number is more important
orders what if you noticed see this
kortek that I am write down right do you
see it's got a term here X to the 4 as
an X cubed there's an x squared I don't
have any X terms in there not like here
and here and here okay
but it doesn't matter right in fact
you'd have to write this one down if all
I had was that X to the 4 it's already
according because it's got that number
out the front there right and you can
add anything else to that that you'd
like these other things are much less
important than that biggest number up
there
whichever the biggest number is it's
kind of the one that takes the driver's
seat and takes earner and defines what's
going on so therefore it's super
important we call that number there
interview one or two or three or four we
call that highest power
we call it the degrees okay
the degree is whatever is the highest
power in your polynomial so I'll just
write that that's the highest power you
can find it doesn't have to be out the
front you know I could write see this
guy here I could write five take away X
to the four but the X to the four is the
most important term right you can think
about this in terms of our functions
right remember we said these are all
functions you can put a number in we're
gonna number out okay if I put in
numbers like same zero or one or two
really literal numbers okay all of these
numbers on the end they really matter
right like five is a lot bigger than
zero one or two
hey is a lot bigger than zero or one or
two okay but if the numbers you're
putting into your function are huge if
they're enormous like a million or a
billion or a trillion what difference is
5 or 6 or negative 1 or 8 what
difference does that make
when you raise it you know to the fourth
power the answer is hardly any
difference at all okay
like if I'm looking at this guy a
million it's the power of four that's
one with 24 zeros after it and then
there's a note we don't really care at
the eighties small is inconsequential
okay now that's obvious that's one of
these numbers on the end but in fact
it's all of those terms only that guy is
the one which really drives things okay
so since he's so important we attach a
few other things to this right so this
whole term here right the one which has
the degree on it you've ever I said a
polynomial just means me turns this
whole term we call the leading term it's
the term that is the most important out
of all the terms right there I mean they
all matter kind of okay but this is the
one which really makes a difference
okay because it's the leading term the
number out the front of the leading term
is kind of important to me as well
for instance st. see these two here
right the leading term here is
before the leading term here is minus x
over four okay that number at the front
which in this case is minus one or in
this case is one makes a big difference
in fact in this case it turns the whole
thing upside down okay
so because that number is so important
I'm running out of space here but I'm
gonna do it anyway in this case it's a
two I'm gonna put it the number in front
of a preview rule like X or Y or theta
or something like that is generally
called as they were going to start to
the same coefficient very good we'll get
to the constant in a second okay so this
here this error is going to do the whole
the whole bubble right by just the two
that coefficient cuz it's humble in turn
we call that the leading coefficient
it's the coefficient on the leading term
okay excuse me you've got all these
other terms they had their own other
coefficients there's one more term that
matters to me which is matter
significantly enough that it gets its
own name now it's the one pension
actually this one on the end okay it's
one of the end remember a function
changes its value depending on what
inputs you lay into it right if it's 0
or 1 or 2 or hundred all of these bits
with X's they'll all change and they'll
all vary but this 8 and this negative 1
and this 6 and is 5 they don't care what
X is right they don't get bigger they
don't get smaller they're always the
same size no matter what X is that means
they're constant they don't change
so in fact we call it the constant term
the contents constant terms really handy
right remember in a y equals MX plus B
form of a straight line because that is
just your y-intercept the exactly right
in fact the constant is always the y
intercept the y intercept of this
quadratic will be 6 and the y intercept
of this cubic will be negative 1 and I
have no idea what this quadrant look
like it looks like but I know it's Y no
sense will be 8 ok so here are our
important pieces these are like language
that we're going to use and
over and over again as we do some actual
operations on polynomials